[Musique]
notre invité vous accompagne depuis près
de 40 ans dans les grands événements
sportifs se diffusés par France
Télévisions les JO Roland-Garros les
Mondiaux d'athlétisme le patinage
artistique les plus grands champions
sont passés à son micro vous savez ce
micro qu'il tend à peine quelques
minutes après une victoire ou une
défaite ce micro qu'il tombe parfois
avec un peu de fébrilité parce qu'il y a
une émotion positive ou négative à aller
chercher chez le sportif d'ailleurs
c'est un peu son sport à lui sa prouesse
son exploit et même après plus de 30 ans
il le fait toujours avec autant d'envie
de fougues de gourmandise je dirais
aussi de délicatesse car il en faut pour
approcher des sportifs de haut niveau au
summum de leur concentration ou au pire
moment de leur carrière se sont-ils
d'ailleurs de trop parfois a-t-il
l'impression de déranger comment fait-il
pour gérer l'exigence du métier de
journaliste et l'autre exigence plus
humaine de respecter l'émotion de
l'autre posant lui toutes ces questions
bienvenue dans un monde à regarder
Nelson Monfort merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ici au Dôme Tournon au
Sénat vous êtes quand même toujours sur
un fil non c'est un peu ce que
j'expliquais en introduction vous avez
une position un peu compliquée parfois
oui c'est exact parce que c'est pour ça
que j'aime bien le terme de passeur
d'émotions parce que c'est exactement ce
que vous disiez c'est que les émotions
peuvent être positives alors quand elles
sont positives c'est assez facile de se
réjouir c'est la fête etc donc je
participe à cette fête en revanche c'est
beaucoup plus délicat c'est un autre mot
que vous avez employé quand ces émotions
sont négatives en cas de défaite c'est
beaucoup plus difficile et c'est là
justement où la pudeur la délicatesse
doit jouer j'espère qu'au bout de comme
vous le disiez de 30 ans en fait j'ai
célébré mon jubilé et l'an dernier 1992
2000-2022 j'ai acquis une certaine
expérience mais mais c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours ça en tête et est-ce que vous
disiez être très juste également le fait
de ne pas se sentir de trop le fait
d'être comment dire parfois comme une
petite souris qui acceptez-vous deux ou
n'acceptez-vous pas tout ça c'est venu
avec l'expérience oui je pense même au
moment avant le match et je pense à
cette scène avec Gael Monfils où on sent
qu'il est extrêmement concentré et
d'ailleurs vous n'insistez pas à vous
sentez que ce n'est pas le moment pour
lui oui certainement pas l'interview la
plus longue que j'ai faite parce que
exactement le en plus je me souviens de
cette période avec une certaine
nostalgie que c'était à l'époque où il
était une semaine français jouait quand
même à peu près les premiers rôles
autour de Roland Garros qui n'est plus
le cas depuis plusieurs années donc
c'est là je m'en souviens plus tôt avec
parce que cette vété en car peut-être
même de mes finales donc c'est une
époque malheureusement un petit peu
révolue et comment ça se passe après
quel rapport vous avez avec ces sportifs
est-ce qu'il vous tape dans le dos en
vous disant bon j'étais concentré Nelson
désolé ou quels sont vos échanges avec
eux hors antenne alors c'était les gens
que vous parliez de Gael Monfils du coup
c'est un bon exemple parce que que ce
soit lui avec son papa qui porte un
prénom original Rufin mon fils
j'ai plein j'ai plein d'anecdotes par
exemple
je suis avec le père de mon fils comme
il a un nom un jeu de mots c'est assez
facile et tout ça m'a permis d'avoir
avec gérer le clan et c'est le mot le
clan mon fils un rapport on privilégier
maintenant pour répondre directement à
votre question je n'ai jamais cherché à
comment dire à célébrer la troisième
mi-temps c'est leur moment ce n'est pas
le mien je n'ai jamais cessé pour
reprendre ce que vous venez de dire à
taper dans d'autres c'est leur moment ce
n'est pas le mien et les rares fois où
on m'a convié ou je ne pouvais
difficilement dire non je ne me sentais
pas à ma place j'ai souvent pensé mais
c'est exactement la même chose vous
savez pour des pour des artistes des
chanteurs des danseurs des réalisateurs
que sais-je leur moment c'est le moment
où ils sont sur scène où ils peuvent
vous apporter le meilleur de ce qu'ils
ont je n'ai jamais été par exemple un
fan d'aller voir un artiste dans la loge
après le après sa performance il vient
de me montrer ce qu'il a de meilleur
après
vous ne pouvez quasiment presque tout le
temps qu'elle est haut devant de
déception donc l'admiration oui l'amitié
la complicité aussi mais l'amitié c'est
autre chose et j'en suis parfaitement
conscient est-ce qu'il y a des sportifs
que vous n'approchez même pas parce que
vous savez qu'ils seront froids distants
vous dites à votre rédaction non lui
c'est pas possible
non non parce que parce que c'est mon
métier vous le disiez quelques minutes
c'est le mon métier de journaliste alors
il y en a certains évidemment avec
lesquels le contact est plus chaleureux
évidemment mais de ne pas avoir approché
je n'ai je n'ai pas de souvenirs je n'ai
pas de souvenirs là dedans parce que
c'est mon métier encore une fois il y a
des personnes avec laquelle ça fait tilt
et des personnes avec lesquelles c'est
plus difficile mais j'ai toujours essayé
de de faire de mon mieux et d'aller vers
tous vous parliez de sportifs adorable
je pense évidemment Rafael Nadal que
dont vous ne cessez de faire l'éloge
parce que vous dites qu'il est quelqu'un
d'adorable oui c'est à dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui allait oui
s'il faut répondre
directement je me suis pas trop trop
échou avec 14 victoires Roland Garros
c'est c'est non c'est vrai que lui c'est
un garçon qui que ce soit lui sa famille
son oncle tonique était son ex
entraîneur son clan parce que là aussi
son clan avec Carlos Moya avec des gens
comme ça sont des gens qui avaient que
j'aime beaucoup que sur le cours c'est
difficile de pas l'aimer sans palmarès
voilà parle pour lui mais également dans
les gestes assez amusant parce que je
vous fais une petite confidence chaque
année à la fin du tournoi Roland-Garros
nous faisons un sondage pour savoir qui
des joueurs est le plus sympathique etc
et oui et ce sondage nous faisons auprès
des ramasseurs de balles qui est plus
près des joueurs et des joueuses que les
ramasseurs de balles et vous avez
sûrement constaté il y a une manière de
je sais pas il y a une manière par
exemple de jeter la serviette un peu
négligemment ou de la tendre poliment
etc et bien Rafa répond à tous ces
critères et c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois
mais à chaque fois il arrive en tête et
largement en tête des des joueurs les
plus agréables
parmi les moments forts que vous avez
vécu les moments historiques vous en
parlez dans mémoire olympique votre
livre paru chez elle chez Michel Lafont
il y a ceux avec les nageurs de l'équipe
de France moi ça m'a beaucoup marqué
vous êtes au JO de Londres 2012 lors du
4 x 100 m ils ne sont pas favoris et
pourtant ils gagnent Amaury Leveaux vous
prend dans ses bras Yannick Agnel vous
glissent à l'oreille que vous étiez le
cinquième relayeur alors là c'est
magnifique de vivre ça oui je me dis
qu'au fond là ce métier vaut la peine
d'être vécu parce que je crois en avoir
on parlait il y a quelques instants de
se réjouir d'une victoire je crois en
avoir jamais vu quatre jeunes gens aussi
heureux c'est à dire que vraiment comme
vous le dit très bien il devait non
seulement il devait pas gagner cette
course il devait terminer entre 3e et 5e
peut-être quatrième la fameuse place que
tout que tout le monde déteste et il
gagne il gagne la course et c'est vrai
que ce jour-là alors ce jour-là moi je
sentais tellement et Yannick
effectivement me glissait à l'oreille et
j'étais content qu'il me le dise à
l'oreille et non pas à l'antenne parce
que si on l'église à l'antenne on va
encore penser que voilà j'avais prévu de
faire tout ça aujourd'hui il faut faire
attention à tout ça en réparation
et et là ce jour-là c'est vrai que j'en
garde je me présente après j'en garde
encore un souvenir extraordinaire c'est
sportifs de haut niveau qu'est-ce qui
vous fait signe chez eux la le fait de
pouvoir comment dire répondre présent le
jour J il y a une telle pression il y a
une telle il y a une telle le cœur bat à
100 à l'heure et de pouvoir répondre le
présent aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas des sportifs français
d'ailleurs je vais vous faire sourire il
y a une il y a une fédération qui s'est
lancé qui s'appelle la Fédération
Française de la Luz alors ce sont tous
les comment les malheureux ceux qui
terminent 4e ceux qui sont disqualifiés
sur tapis vert ou je ne sais quoi et et
malheureusement c'est assez souvent le
cas des sportifs français qui ont du mal
mais c'est la vérité souvent souvent des
gens quand ils évoluent à domicile
souvent quand est souvent quand ils sont
favoris alors là je peux vous je peux y
aider des dizaines d'exemples le sport
français de façon générale et bon comme
outsider et moins bon comme favori alors
on peut expliquer partout mais je pense
quand même que c'est vrai que c'est ce
mot a été mis un petit peu à toutes les
sauces mais le mot de pression surtout à
domicile jouer énormément je donne pas
mal d'exemples justement dans dans mon
livre que vous mettez allusion il y a un
sport que vous regrettez de ne pas avoir
couvert de ne pas avoir commenté je
pense notamment au football je crois que
vous l'avez jamais fait par exemple le
football n'est pas trop sur notre chaîne
mon regret effectivement c'est de pas
commenter le Tour de France cycliste
parce que mais comment mes amis mais
hiérarchie comme on dit le savent donc
je peux je fais d'autant plus à l'aise
de vous le dire parce que effectivement
le Tour de France cycliste c'est pas
seulement autour de France c'est le tour
de la France avec son patrimoine ses
richesses ses écrivains ses artistes
tout ça et c'est vrai que mais peut-être
n'est-il pas trop je voudrais qu'on se
penche un petit peu sur votre histoire
personnelle parce qu'elle est riche
culturellement déjà vous l'avez dit d'un
mot vous êtes d'origine néerlando
américaine votre mère était néerlandaise
votre père était américain ils vous ont
eu assez tard ils étaient relativement
âgés et vous avez perdu très jeune
lorsque vous aviez 23 et 27 ans vous
étiez leur seul enfant qu'est-ce que le
fait d'avoir eu cette histoire assez
singulière vous a apporté est-ce que ça
vous a apporté une sensibilité
particulière une sensibilité aux
émotions des autres et d'ailleurs la
boucle est bouclée alors déjà était en
fils unique et comme vous venez de le
dire de parents qui en fait auraient pu
être mes grands-parents d'une certaine
manière
ça m'a permis de me comment de me
constituer des amitiés fraternelles tout
au long du chemin et encore aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas de frère et sœur mais j'ai
des amis qui sont comme des frères et
sœurs et il y a cette fameuse chanson
c'est avant de Choisy pas sa famille on
choisit ses amis c'est Maxime Le
Forestier de mémoire j'adore cette
chanson parce que parce que en tout cas
ce qui me concerne c'est tout à fait
vrai et c'est vrai tous les jours je me
suis vraiment fait encore récemment des
amis tout au long du chemin qui sont
vraiment devenus des eux-mêmes qui ont
des frères et sœurs et dont je me dis
peut-être qu'ils sont peut-être plus
proche de moi que de leur faire achats
qui n'ont pas choisi pas pas
systématiquement mais je fais partie un
peu de leur femme en tout cas eux font
partie de la mienne et vous avez un côté
citoyen du monde et vous évoluez dans un
univers ou toutes les nationalités
énormément toutes les nationalités
toutes les religions toutes les couleurs
toutes les races toutes les sports comme
l'athlétisme par exemple c'est un océan
de tout ce que j'aime c'est un océan de
tout ce que j'aime dans la vie c'est
c'est la c'est la tolérance c'est le
c'est le sourire c'est le j'adore ce
sport parce que l'athlétisme d'ailleurs
je devrais dire c'est sport parce que
entre un cheval entre un sauteur en
longueur et un lanceur de poids il y a
pas beaucoup il y a pas beaucoup de
points communs mais c'est vrai que vous
parliez de natation et quelques minutes
c'est vrai qu'en athlétisme aussi j'ai
des souvenirs extraordinaires quoi de
faire dialoguer ça j'adore faire
dialoguer les uns et les autres parfois
le vainqueur les nations entre elles par
exemple de faire dialoguer
Usain Bolt avec Christophe Le pour moi
ce sont des souvenirs formidables
formidables vous ne deviez pas
spécialement faire du journalisme
sportif au départ je crois que vous avez
vous deviez faire carrière dans la
banque l'industrie ou le commerce
international vous avez fait Sciences Po
à Paris c'est ça
effectivement d'ailleurs je suis passé
devant en venant en venant vous voir oui
je non je ne sais pas je n'étais pas
vraiment destiné à ça mais cela dit le
point commun que je retrouve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous parliez de banque ou
de finances de façon générale dans le
sport aujourd'hui ça compte beaucoup
c'est pas faux ça compte énormément
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le comment
dire ça vous faire sourire mais le
carnet de chèques est intimement lié au
sport au sport du du 21e siècle trop ah
ouais beaucoup trop oui beaucoup trop on
peut me dire tout ce qu'on veut oui je
vous répondrai honnêtement je veux pas
vous répondre avec des artifices j'ai
rien de justifie certaines il y a deux
choses 1 rien ne justifie certaines
rémunérations et rien ne justifie
secondo des différences aussi grandes
d'une discipline à l'autre à l'allure de
celui que vous êtes aujourd'hui Nelson
Monfort quels conseils donneriez-vous au
petit garçon ou au jeune homme que vous
étiez que lui diriez-vous avant qu'il ne
se lance dans la vie
en tout cas
concernant ma modeste personne moi-même
je lui dirai aujourd'hui que l'adulte
que je suis devenu n'a pas trahi
l'enfant que j'étais
ça c'est vrai ça c'est vrai je ne pense
pas avoir été comment dire indigne de
cette profession j'ai
enfin je crois enfin ceux qui me
connaissent le savent j'ai une éthique
qui m'accompagne non seulement dans
cette profession mais également dans la
vie qui fait que voilà que que je peux
pour prendre un cliché me regarder dans
la glace ça ça je peux le faire donc à
partir de là la trahison ça aurait été
quoi la trahison ça aurait été justement
de de faire ce journaliste de caniveau
que que je n'aime pas du tout d'ailleurs
je j'en profite pour quand même rendre
un certain hommage à la presse française
de façon générale parce que je connais
la presse anglo-américaine et notamment
Angleterre pas très loin d'ici ou là
vraiment les plus mauvais sentiments la
presse anglaise que vous connaissez sans
doute comme moi peut-être d'une dureté
terrible terrible nous franchement nous
sommes des enfants de chœur à côté bon
tout le monde je dis pas que tout le
monde sont les saints ici mais enfin
j'ai voilà nous n'avons pas de leçon
d'éthique à recevoir de qui que ce soit
même si je suis conscient que les fameux
réseau sociaux que j'appelle encore une
fois fléau sociaux fait énormément de
mal à cette profession je voudrais vous
montrer un document qui nous vient de
nos partenaires les Archives nationales
Nelson Montfort je vais vous laisser le
découvrir et je vais le décrire pour les
gens qui nous écoutent c'est la photo du
voyage officiel du président Pompidou à
Munich à l'occasion des Jeux Olympiques
nous sommes là sur cette photo le 9
septembre 1972 on voit de larges sourire
de la fierté et on est pourtant trois
jours après la prise d'otage et
l'assassinat de 11 athlètes israéliens
par les membres de l'organisation
palestinienne septembre noire quel
contraste d'ailleurs entre ces sourires
et le drame qui vient de se jouer vous
vous souvenez vous de ces jeux
je m'en souviens d'autant plus que ici
sur la sur la gauche le barbu ici n'est
autre marque-pageot le navigateur et le
président Pompidou qui est effectivement
ici je m'en souviens d'autant plus que
l'été dernier donc l'été 2022 nous
étions à Munich au même stade
pour les championnats d'Europe
d'athlétisme et donc il y a je sais pas
si vous dire un Mémoria un musée un
mémorial où je suis allé et je peux vous
dire que ça ne laisse pas indifférent
parce qu'il vous il vous raconte toute
la comment dire toute la fin toute la
l'évolution de cette ça a été je crois
le je développe aussi simple dans mon
livre si je crois que c'était le pire
moment du sport mondial et rien que d'en
parler encore aujourd'hui sur toute la
façon dont ça s'est passé rien que d'en
parler encore aujourd'hui me enfin même
et parfois même me dire des larmes CC et
et cette cette assassinat parce qu'il
faut bien parler de ça à totalement
transformé le sport mondial c'est
qu'avant parce que ce qu'il faut je vous
fais l'histoire courte ouais il faut
savoir c'est qu'en septembre pour les
Jeux Olympiques de 1972 donc à Munich
nous étions donc une vingtaine d'années
enfin 25 et quelques années après la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale et les
Allemands voulaient ouvrir tout
c'est-à-dire voulait paraître l'inverse
de ce qu'ils avaient été 25 ans avant
vous n'allez pas me croire Rebecca on
pouvait s'introduire au jour au village
olympique comme dans une boulangerie je
rentre aucun contrôle rien du tout les
athlètes la proximité mais aucun aucun
contrôle aujourd'hui ça paraît
totalement irréel et et c'est ce dont
les terroristes sont profondément
j'avais plus ou moins revêtu des tenues
avec des jogging ce genre de choses mais
ils ont laissé en fait et dans leur sac
il y avait non pas des des commandes des
raquettes de tennis il y avait des
mitraillettes ils les ont laissé rentrer
les sas de sécurité n'existaient
absolument pas et ça c'était en fait
comment dire c'était la volonté de il y
avait aucun aucune force de police
scotch je connais bien l'histoire il y
avait aucune force de police il y avait
rien donc ça a été une une
et c'est cette comment cette
impréparation volontaire dirais-je
assisté cette tragédie si on prend
l'histoire des jeux dans leur ensemble
on s'aperçoit que c'est quand même
toujours un moment politique un moment
géopolitique un moment d'action alors là
d'attentat gravissime mais aussi
d'action de tous ordres
assassiné et là le parallèle n'est
peut-être pas juste mais on parle
beaucoup des JO de Paris 2024 on se
demande si les athlètes russes si on
leur place ou pas leur place on voit que
c'est un moment politique vous le
regrettez ça ou pas c'est à dire que ça
vient éclipser le sport c'est à dire
qu'il y a eu moi je peux vous citer
comme ça à 5 ou 6 éditions des Jeux
olympiques ou là où la politique
mondiale était intimement mêlée à au
sport ou comme vous voulez les Jeux
Olympiques de Berlin 36 qui ont
constitué un peu l'apogée du nazisme les
Jeux olympiques de Mexico 68 vous en
souvenez sûrement avec les points le
voilà alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que l'année 68 aux États-Unis avait vu
des des violences terribles avait vu
l'assassin alors des deux personnes qui
pouvaient
la communauté noire pouvait encore
croire à savoir Martin Luther King et
Robert Kennedy à deux mois d'écart donc
c'est ambiance était plombante et été
terrible et effectivement les Noirs
américains qui en plus en octobre 68 au
jeu de Mexico tout gagné tout gagner
ajouté au fait que le président du
comité olympique mondial Avery Brenda
j'étais un homme d'un conservatisme
d'une autre époque tout était lié à ça
mais vous le regrettez ou pas vous à
titre personnel En tant que spécialiste
du monde du sport oui mais vous trouvez
que du coup ça vient parasiter les
prouesses des sportifs leur exploits
leur travail
je trouve que une tribune comme celle-là
est juste énorme et je trouve vous savez
qu'ils ont énormément souffert James et
John Carlos c'est donc deux qui s'agit
ils ont été mis de côté mis à l'écart
comment ils ont été mais plus que plus
que pénalisés
pendant pendant 30 ans ils n'ont
recouvré leur honneur que 30 ans après
dans un autre registre au niveau plus
local les compétitions sportives sont
souvent l'occasion d'action militante et
c'est arrivé récemment pendant Roland
Garros pour alerter sur le climat à tel
point que la ministre des Sports a voulu
y mettre fin et une loi pénalise
aujourd'hui ses actions le fait de
pénétrer ou de tenter de pénétrer par
force ou parfois dans une enceinte
sportive lors d'une compétition peut
être punie de 6 mois de prison et de
7500 euros d'amende vous comprenez que
il y a deux choses parce que bon le
comment le mouvement des blagues
Panthers etc je là c'est quand même
quelque chose de qui qui secoue le cœur
qui secoue l'intime de ces deux de ses
champions qui était persécutés puisqu'il
y a pas d'autres mots vous savez que les
médaillés d'or des Jeux olympiques de
mexic et même plus tard des médaillés
d'or olympiques se sont retrouvés
gardiens de parking de nuit c'est ça
aussi moi je suis extrêmement
comment attacher et souvent interpellé
par la reconversion des sportifs ça
c'est autre chose en revanche des
personnes extérieures qui viennent
s'attacher au filet de Roland-Garros je
trouve que c'était là c'était pas les
tennisman c'était des militants
écologistes
c'est pas le lieu c'est pas le non on va
pas je fais une grande différence entre
les deux
on va passer à notre séquence photo si
vous le voulez bien Nelson Monfort j'ai
trois photos à vous proposer la première
la voici il s'agit de Léon Zitrone et de
Guy Lux alors je vous vois déjà rire
mais non les présente plus les présente
quand même pour les plus jeunes d'entre
nous qui nous écoutent de star du petit
écran de quoi animateur inséparable
entre 1962 et 1990 ils ont animé le jeu
télévisé Intervilles vous aussi non
exact
la dernière année d'ailleurs je crois
que ce jeu n'a pas survie à mon
animation probablement Léo Zitrone qui a
commenté le couronnement d'Elisabeth II
aussi il n'a pas fait que qu'intervie
est-ce qu'un événement planétaire non
sportif vous aimeriez le commenter je
pense je sais pas vous auriez aimé
commenté le couronnement de Charles III
par exemple oui enfin il y a d'autres
vous savez si je vous dis tout ce que je
moi je suis déjà assez content avec ce
que je fais on peut pas tout bien faire
là en l'occurrence je pense que je
j'aurais peut-être pu le faire le faire
assez bien mais oui parce que je connais
bien la Grande-Bretagne ça va mais voilà
c'est c'est voilà d'autres d'autres
personnes font font ça très bien
commencé votre phrase
il y a quelques années absolument à deux
reprises d'ailleurs de mémoire donc non
non après il y a eu la crise sanitaire
etc donc non non je peux
j'estime pouvoir faire autre chose que
d'aller comment interpeller les sportifs
avec la sueur dans les dans les
vestiaires après un événement oui une
autre photo il s'agit piliers du Stade
français Paul aloemile qui revient sur
les terrains prennent lourde dépression
on entend aujourd'hui que quelques
rugbymen professionnels souffrent
d'épisodes dépressifs de Burnout
Matthieu Bastareaud et Pascal Papet on
avait déjà parlé avec tiré la sonnette
d'alarme il y a plusieurs années le
rugby c'est pas forcément votre sport
mais j'imagine que vous avez un avis sur
ces dépressions de sportifs dont il
parle plus librement aujourd'hui c'est
un vrai sujet
et je dirais que c'est un sujet pendant
la carrière ce qui était un peu plus
rare mais c'est surtout un sujet juste
après quand je dis juste après c'est
juste après d'ailleurs puis-je vous
parler de rugby c'est le rugbyman de
nicha avec vous connaissez probablement
qui avait parlé de petites morts
qu'est-ce que c'est la petite mort c'est
quand on arrête sa carrière c'est pas
tellement c'est pas seulement la
question de rémunération dans le rugby
en plus rémunération sont pas énormes
mais c'est surtout le fait il y a plus
la lumière et la lumière s'éteint très
vite c'est pas qu'elle c'est un
progressivement elle s'éteint quasiment
tout de suite et la petite mort c'est ça
vous avez vu des sportifs j'en ai vu
beaucoup et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle c'est drôle parce que vous
savez on dit oui il a fait le combat de
trop il a fait l'année de trop etc mais
si vous avez un sportif qui était
mettons en premier ou deuxième et qu'il
allait quand il arrive à 35 36 ans et 3e
ou 4e mais troisième ou quatrième ils se
sont quand même encore performant ce
sont encore performant si difficile
d'arrêter si vous avez un exemple d'un
sportif que vous avez vu tomber sombrer
sombré peut-être sombrer c'est peut-être
un j'ai l'exemple par exemple de
d'athlète français de de de fille de
voilà par exemple une fille comme
Patricia Girard qui était hordeleuse
voilà c'est un assez bon exemple parce
que je crois que elle était médaille
d'argent peut-être ou elle était même
sur le podium olympique je veux pas
exactement en tête d'argent ou de bronze
elle a continué effectivement peut-être
un petit peu trop longtemps par rapport
à ses performances mais elle était cinq
sixième etc mais il faut savoir
également ce qu'on ce qu'on va faire
après il y a même un athlète français
champion olympique de saut à la qui
s'est suicidé je médaille d'or olympique
au jeu de Los Angeles il a lui il a
vraiment sombré et
enfin voilà je trouve ça vraiment plus
que révoltant c'est c'est retrouver
imaginé vous n'avez pas le croire il
vendait des poulets sur une aire
d'autoroute
pas assez c'est sportif ça c'est certain
aujourd'hui mieux aujourd'hui davantage
mais pendant des années ça a été le
néant une dernière photo peut-être plus
symbolique et qui va toucher vous
touchez plus personnellement vous allez
comprendre pourquoi Johan Cabaye qui est
un ancien footballeur professionnel
ancien milieu des Bleus un sportif qui
n'a jamais caché sa foi très croyant il
se rendait fréquemment à la cathédrale
Notre-Dame de la Treille à Lille et j'ai
pensé parce que je crois savoir que vous
êtes vous aussi croyant et que vous
aviez même un petit rituel avant Roland
Garros
on ne peut rien vous cacher on peut rien
vous cacher effectivement bon là c'est
de là ça touche un peu à l'intime mais
c'est vrai que alors déjà j'ai beaucoup
de sympathie pour voilà bon moi il se
trouve que je suis je suis protestant
mais c'est vrai que j'ai une ouais j'ai
une fois et puis surtout j'ai une
tolérance je alors ça c'est peut-être dû
à mes origines comme je suis dans une
religion qui a beaucoup souffert à
travers les siècles beaucoup beaucoup
souffert à travers les siècles j'ai
cette tolérance qui est de d'accueillir
toute forme de de religion et de
croyance et effectivement j'ai j'ai un
petit rituel d'aller effectivement dans
une église que j'ai visualise très bien
à Boulogne juste avant toi tennis de
Roland Garros c'est dans quelques
semaines mais c'est pas tabou dans le
sport le fait d'être croyant de ce signe
avant d'entrer sur un terrain c'est
presque un univers où finalement être il
est en pratiquant c'est moins gênant
qu'ailleurs beaucoup ont de croyances
des superstitions aussi c'est exact
stratégies j'y pense avec votre votre
observation qui est très juste derrière
ce que les pattes tellement d'autres
parce que dans les arts ça ne se vend en
tout cas ça ne se voit pas là évidemment
là ça se voit parce que c'est filmé donc
pas les sportifs on les voit non c'est
exact c'est une bonne et j'ai le
sentiment même je vais même plus loin je
sens le même que tu en as de plus en
plus une dernière question qui est en
lien avec notre lieu et qui est un autre
rituel de cette émission Nelson Monfort
nous sommes entouré de quatre statues
qui représentent chacune une vertu la
sagesse la prudence la justice et
derrière moi l'éloquence est-ce qu'il y
en a une en quelques mots qui vous parle
et pourquoi
je dirais peut-être l'éloquence qui est
derrière vous parce que bon malgré tout
vous et moi sommes dans un dans un
métier de communication j'ai c'est vrai
que voilà que que l'éloquence
l'enthousiasme la bonne utilisation de
la langue française ça j'y tiens
énormément ce qu'on me dit parfois oui
c'est formidable tu parles l'anglais
l'espagnol c'est vrai je pense que la
première responsabilité due à un
journaliste je sais que vous allez
d'accord avec moi c'est le respect de
notre langue qui est peut-être la plus
belle langue qui soit donc je dirais
qu'il fallait choisir entre les quatre
j'aime bien les quatre mais je dirais
peut-être l'éloquence et bien c'est
votre choix merci infiniment Nelson
Monfort d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis comme chaque semaine à très
bientôt sur Public Sénat merci quelles
sont
[Musique]